des parents aux enfants l'expression
d'un ras-le-bol général sont une
cinquantaine à s'être réunis dans la
ville rose contre le port du masque à
l'école redoutant des effets collatéraux
sur la santé de leurs enfants nés
parents tirent la sonnette d'alarmé il
ya beaucoup de pédiatres et tout ça qui
montrent que c'est que le port du masque
ne sert à rien pour les enfants et
surtout qu'il est hyper contre-productif
j'ai un enfant
bien sûr bien sûr il a 7 ans oui
absolument
j'hésite à le déscolarisés ils adorent
et l'école mais ça le ca le pen
énormément il n'a plus le goût d'aller à
l'école et tout ça monfils clairement
bain ne peut pas porter le masque
ça le rend malade voilà mais en même
temps les médecins semblent ne pas être
autorisés à faire des certificats
médicaux et donc on me coince perte de
motivation développement des bactéries
le port du masque peut aussi représenter
une gêne dans l'apprentissage et j'aime
pas trop parce que ça me fait de la vue
sur les lunettes
j'aime pas trop belle parce que
genton n'entend pas les personnes face à
ce phénomène et alors que la crise
sanitaire s'éternise certains parents
préfèrent des scolariser leurs enfants